the Joe Rogan experience dude speaking
of people again [ __ ] up how about that
girl side worked five Chuck scared when
she got hit with the first one her eyes
were like oh my god and God bless her
man because your first fight in UFC here
you go this is what you guys want here's
cyborg main event short notice
enjoy that yeah that's kind of a crazy
thing to do right
tidal shot your first fight ever in the
UFC title shot in first Friday ever
nobody knows literally nobody in the UFC
knows who you are
you see they even have a picture up of
her till they kill the fight you've
never I mean she got submitted by Tonya
avenger' that's tough she submitted
Tonya and Tonya submitted her and we
know that she's a 135 her yeah that's
her like wincing in pain
cyborg lowers the board down though she
did that weird
yeah well that was obviously the
strategy the strategy was to close the
distance
get that clinch dragged side work to the
ground she's a 135 her man she really
it's not big enough but for cyborg it's
like what do you want me to do man like
there's no one in the division what is
stopping that Megan Anderson chick from
coming over her work visa
she was here illegally or something like
that no that was that hold up there Oh
some [ __ ] lawyers cuz I know man
let's go cuz she's a legit you know
character big girl Eddie Australian yeah
fighter a saw tattooed up she's actually
one you know she's in the same weight
class 145 yeah yeah and she wants the
fight you know freaky cat Zingano want
the fight - she's talking all that [ __ ]
someone call Trump I can't get it done
Katzie gana wants to fight well well
Katsucon oh did want the cyborg fight
but since she lost that last one right
yeah split decision unique in Sai where
he's not sniffing no no no no no there's
no way she's gonna have to get a couple
of it cuz she lost her last one - she
took Giuliana pin yeah yeah
she's taking too much you could see the
ring russ was there and the nerves are
there she's she she needs time she's
time she can compete there with cyborg
I'm trying to be funny here she's not
gonna lose to a single woman you need it
she needs to fight to women or there
needs to be a dude in there but one
girl's not gonna beat her I hate to tell
you guys like this just not
I don't know how you're gonna market
that you tell me you wouldn't watch her
ever CM Punk well I think you put her as
co-main event a lot and some cards that
have a lot of great fights I just think
that the people are always willing to
watch whoever steps in and fights her
but to have her be the center of a giant
event I think it's gonna take a real
challenger like Holly those ratings were
good like yeah that was a good fight
because that was a fight with people
like hmm Holly you know is legit like
real skillful box shows you how good a
decision although she you know Holly was
never really winning that fight she
wasn't yeah she got blit up you realized
when you're in their fighting cyborg
it's totally different proposition when
you see cyber is like oh man she's never
gonna lose until father time my guest
touches around the shoulder right now
she's only 32 you know crazy it's not
young but it's not old either no she's
not old shitty prime she dudes for
another five years easy when you know
you think about how long she's been
around like we're back to the Gina
Carano fight how old was she then Jesus
man super young super young she'd been
doing for a minute dude you ever watch
that fight again it's not bad fight to
find enough credit no Gina mounted her
at one point Tom Tina first team all
deities captain the team yeah it's
pretty hot but out of respect to Kevin
Ross this would be the end of this
conversation it comes to how hard is
what's he do
Kevin Rasta muy Thai fighter oh yeah
with all these all tatted up they're
still together
yeah good for them too bad for them
hopefully she's right yeah she's got to
be very cool cuz he's very cool yeah
they're both gonna stay beginning a
fight she's just teeing off on gym and
[ __ ] up and Gina Juan's up on top of
her look at Gina doing what people
forget how good that girl with man oh
she's very good look at that
cyborg every girl should give her
royalties for starting women's MMA in
spirit actually half a steel hook here
are half decent heel hook here she an
attorney get out of it
I should popped out yeah Gina chronica I
mean she just he got big Gina crown
would be if she was in the sport right
now Jesus
cyborgs hitting with some hammers this
was yeah she would be gigantic be so
because she was in a break when the UFC
was really in it's in
see we got Showtime what year do you
think this fight was if you had to get
two thousand four six two thousand
really nine Wow
cyborg vicious kick to the body so
cyborg was only like what twenty two ish
or take the shot again and this time
gene amount sir look at that like people
forget gee just getting them out because
cyborgs mistakes at yeah this is the
most troubling we've ever seen cyborg in
besides that Mort I fight and jeans
gonna let her out
no Gina was an absolute monster people
forget man but with cyber I I'm dead
serious
that's true women enter that octagon
against her she's not gonna lose yeah or
unis get khabib up in that [ __ ] well
she obviously has some physical
attributes now when you think about the
rest of the women at 145 no one stands
out what they're gonna do is Amanda
Nunez that's the fight yeah man this
wants it cyborg wants it the the I like
the fight and I think technically Amanda
Nunez is better as far as a technician
as cyborg
however for let's say that's five rounds
even three rounds over those three
rounds she's she I don't think she
possesses the same powers cyborg you
know I'm saying the cyborg hits a girl
you you see it on their face his
stoppage Gina Carano will watch it on
the big screen it's horrific
that's tough one it's horrific when she
gets her down like two hammers and she
drops off more of a cyborg fan I'm more
of cyber fan now back then I was first
team all jido no one wanted that no one
wanted that
did she test positive for this fight uh
no I thought it was after there's
another fight yeah I wasn't this fight
that'd be way bigger news but cyborg a
man does a good fight that's a real life
I just and I'm a huge Amanda Nunez fan I
just think over that time she's gonna
land some shots on cyber so I wanna get
hit but when side work it's you it's
it's just you can't play that game with
her there's no female in the world who
can play that game with her you give me
one optic one you hear you hear it just
doesn't work do you know who knows man
that's interesting it's great right I'm
and it's got legit one punch power legit
smack them up power
real black belt in jujitsu very good at
fighting knows how to fight for the homo
fighter yeah she knows how to fight
forget about all the things that she can
do she puts it together well you know
who can fight cyber cyborg yep she's the
greatest female fighter of all time hard
to argue it's hard to argue right yeah
I'm hard to argue there's some caveats
in there obviously but it's hard to
argue yeah you know some caveats I guess
we're gonna go down that road but still
in the UFC with the USANA testing she's
still the best so that kind of kicks out
the window real well she was the best
back then she tested hot cool now she's
in the strict in the most strict testing
pool of all time she's still dominating
so where's your argument there now well
you know the argument that she retained
all the [ __ ] from when she was taking it
back and they definitely retained
something I'm not everything though as
Hector Lombard - question has to be
doorbell fooled right that's true but
those are men it's different the idea of
you know a guy taking [ __ ] or a girl
taking it don't you think they're
different it's it's different but it's
also it's different there's argument
there but it's not different to the
point where after ten was that 2009 he
said so so after nine years she's still
retaining this muscle mass and she was
born a bigger female that's true -
that's true too
[Applause]